hello and welcome to the new order of
your source for everything anime and
manga and today i come bearing gifts
that you may or
may not wish to receive that's because
hunter hunter is the name of this game
and it is going to be our mission to
discover the 20 worst nine abilities
within the entire series not an old and
easy thing to do by the way and i'm
quite convinced that producing this in
the best abilities list may have driven
me ever so slightly insane but the
results are pretty astounding and you
are going to see some abilities on this
particular list that you probably never
would have considered and just to get
this out of the way from the get-go just
because an ability here is deemed to be
one of the worst does not necessarily
mean that the ability is bad those are
two very different concepts
because even in a group of strictly
speaking excellent things there is
always going to be an empirically best
and an empirically worst
and in fact i would personally love to
have most of the nen abilities that we
are going to showcase here but exactly
how did we deem these 20 hanzo to land
at the bottom of the shame pile
hmm well that brings us to methodology
but if you just want to get straight
into this and you can do so by skipping
to this time however
i would encourage you to stay and for
the uh the less attentive
viewers well we will have a slideshow in
the bottom corner here featuring the
ladies of hunter hunter as well as one
man watch out for the man essentially
though this list ranks none abilities
according to four categories each being
assigned a score out of the lovely
number of 25 which
then added up into an even lovelier
number out of 100 thus giving the
ability
its final placement these categories are
suitability which we shall use to
measure how well
hot2 suits its user now generally i
would like to be as objective as
possible with stuff like this but nenus
is so intrinsically linked to the
desires and needs of its user that we do
need to have this one category next up
though we have versatility which scores
how well an ability can be applied in a
wide variety of situations so we're
really hunting for the well diversified
use versus niche one use applications
our third category is efficiency which
weighs up the cost versus the benefits
of the ability is the aura investment
and any applicable limitations worth the
ultimate output and i will say right
here and now that a lot of the abilities
on this list are
less than efficiently implemented yes
i'm looking at you
chetu and to round things out we have
creativity which is designed to reward
outside of the box thinking but why is
this category important well it's
because many abilities can be quite
creatively thought out but very poorly
implemented take castro's double for
example that ability is manifested in an
incredibly creative fashion for a
natural enhancer however it is
exceptionally poorly optimized that's it
for our
and criteria but one more thing of note
specifically for this video
is that super basic nen uses that could
be considered technically an ability
were not taken into account and by this
i mainly mean aura blasts if i included
those then no joke we would just be
going through a list of 20 horoblas
which is no fun for anyone so instead i
have elected to provide
fun for everyone and we will begin
examining the worst in abilities in the
series with number 20
instant lover wielded by basic this is
going to be the first of many examples
of an ability that is not bad but just
lacks a lot of oomph compared to the
rest of the nenvos it's a very basic use
of manipulation although it's much
harder to activate than most and it also
produces heavily time-restricted results
only allowing base8 to control her
target for 180 minutes really the best
thing i can say about this hatsu is that
it is indeed very well suited to beisei
because you know beautiful woman plus
kissing a type ability is generally
going to work quite well in the grand
scheme of things but with everything
else
it's well it's definitely nothing
special for something i thought was
quite special we now hit 19th place
where we find dr blythe and how could
the ability of a royal guard possibly be
in this here video well it's because
this particular hanzo is just
incredibly poorly thought out it's what
comes of the problem of having nion
infinite aura it means you don't have
to think and maximize every last drop of
aura like a normal person would and in
this case dr blyth was developed on a
complete whim because pito wanted to
battle kite's corpse there was no
consideration to versatility or
efficiency which actually resulted in
pitot being incredibly vulnerable
during the palace invasion and look
while it is a good
ability this is just what happens when a
hatsu was crafted on a whim instead of
in response to a profound need
continuing with our necco theme now in
18th place we have cat's name a very
intriguing hotsu held by
second prince camilla which very
basically explained for anime only
watches allows camilla to use the life
force of those who kill her in order to
resurrect herself so it's just like
killing someone but with a bunch of
extra steps as well as making camilla
completely immune to the concept of
murder highly suitable given her role in
the story but where cat's name falters
is sheer versatility the activation
requirement of needing to be murdered is
it's so extreme that it provides little
option for greater usage and if an
opponent does find out about the ability
then it becomes completely useless so a
very cool power but only in a very
particular context but a great ability
to have in any context would be that of
pressing the subscribe button for the
new world review doing so will result in
consistent injections of hunt hunter
culture being administered straight into
your youtube feed a very powerful
ability perhaps even too powerful to
have been mentioned in this video so
getting back to the other less
desirables in 17th place we have one of
the few abilities on this list that i
would probably
not like to have which is living dead
dolls effectively the power to inhabit
and control a corpse something that in
retrospect would be almost impossible
for anyone but icargo to use due to the
painful nature of inserting one's whole
self into a body but that aside it
didn't actually score too terribly and
it landed above average in suitability
living dead dolls was just unable to
pass that 50
mark for anything else to sixteenth
place we have the sun
and the moon a rare none ability in the
series used by two characters being
crollo and the meteor city elder which
immediately makes suitability quite hard
to rank but given that it was a primary
factor of protecting meteor city as well
as a key feature of chrollo's heavens
arena victory i feel like it's pretty
damn well suited to both and the short
summary of the ability is that you can
imprint sun and moon symbols on anything
and everything and when those two
symbols come into contact they go
boom quite deadly but as with many
abilities here it does lose versatility
points because don't be confused by
krollo's masterful usage of it in the
manga that required like five
other abilities in tandem with it to
work on its own the sun and the moon
it's all right but it's still a very
weird niche hot suit into 15th place now
we discover merman clairvoyance used by
palm siberia which is not to be confused
with her aunt ability wink blue merman
clairvoyance was the original crystal
ball hatsu which allowed palm to view
selected targets after feeding blood to
a mermaid corpse which
and sure and this really is a pretty
decent ability for gathering information
or just
being a creepy voyage but i found it
really difficult to just shovel positive
points into this one it is a good
ability but palm certainly did come up
with a much better incarnation after
becoming part chimera ant
in number 14 we have a hatsu that kind
of surprised me which is dance of the
serpent's bite used by karla to zoldick
surprised me because i was not expecting
to utter the zodiac family name in a
video like this
a very dishonorable but at the same time
it's just not all that impressive of an
ability the way it operates with all the
paper confetti just seems like an
incredibly roundabout way to sever limbs
or even kill a target and as such it
even risks giving your opponent a chance
to strike you back which just seems so
very inefficient for an assassin and i
really don't see a whole lot of
versatility at this stage either but
sure it's slightly above average in
terms of creativity because it is
quite unlikely that many people's minds
would ever wander to such a mechanism at
number 13 we have a very disappointing
ability being 11 black children used by
shots mono
disappointing because i was really
hoping that it would land in 11th place
so that i could make some kind of cool
numbers-based comment but that won't be
happening now
or likely ever but this ability is
pretty meh i mean yes there is a lot of
great benefit in crafting minions to do
tasks but in this case the minions are
hyper restricted in their available
commands and they also require a
shocking investment of aura to produce
all of which results in a stunted hatsu
which cannot take full advantage of its
intended purpose now in 12th place we
have an intriguing little existence
known as edgardon which is wielded by
bill in the manga a cool application of
enhancement that accelerates the growth
of living things and can even be used on
humans to improve their nan abilities
sadly though it's hard to say that this
is well suited to bill given his role as
a bodyguard due to its purely supportive
nature it does have quite a decent score
for efficiency though because an
investment of orphan bill can lead to
much more effective use of nenabilities
by others unfortunately not the user are
very good on specifically though so yeah
it's a nice utility to have
in more group style situations but
certainly not quite what i would be
gunning for and something else i
wouldn't be so keen on is number 11
tiger fist bite the trademark technique
of juan
castro and castro pretty much exists in
this series for a singular purpose which
is to display how nen can be heavily
heavily misused and in this case what
truly tanks tiger fist bite would be
creativity it has practically
none of that it barely qualifies as an
above average invocation of enhancement
and is really only as powerful as it is
due to castro's netfinity it is well
suited to castro due to his profession
but the effect itself would be fairly
efficient to produce even for
non-natural enhancers and that is a
problem in and of itself
if an enhancement ability is easy for
say a conjurer to replicate to even half
or a quarter of the degree of
effectiveness then you probably should
have thought a bit better about your
enhancement prowess
breaking the top 10 now we have hotel
rafflesia from shute mcmahon this is an
ability that i really think has
consistently underperformed in the
series it does have a creative premise
i'll give it that but its implementation
leans more and more on the inefficient
side because to completely trap an
opponent or even trap most of them you
will basically need to give them
a full body massage and yes the first
hit on an opponent is going to be quite
disorienting but this is another one of
those powers that just does not do
enough in a timely manner the cost and
methodology of implementation really do
outweigh the results but once again
i do quite like the idea something i
like a lot less is our 9th place
finisher scissorhands brought to us
by benalt he cut some hair with his
favorite of scissors then eats the hair
to learn physical information about the
target so that's pretty funky i'm sure
it has a use in applied science
somewhere but it's definitely not quite
suited to bernal it actually seems very
pito-esque really bernoullt's wanting to
satisfy this desire to learn more about
those he kills rather than assisting the
process
of delivering said kill so versatility
like much of my body here in the shower
is down the drain but to balance that
out it is at the very least
quite creative i do have to give it that
also quite creative is number eight a
little known ability called predator
used by an even lesser known character
rehan and this one is a bit complex to
explain but it essentially acts as an
instant win condition against any target
so long as you meet a plethora of crazy
criteria which is very difficult and
re-hunt himself is actually called the
hatsu highly inaccurate
and a very risky ability so the only
place where it truly thrives is
suitability due to rihann's current
situation in the succession war but i
mean
in theory and i want to stress in theory
this is an ability that could defeat
marijuana because the idea is that the
predator
over quite some time evolves into the
natural predator of the target but in
meruem's case it would be nigh on
impossible to pull off so it's high risk
high reward except the reward is always
the death of someone or something else
so in effect it's actually high risk for
painfully niche results in seventh place
we now find freedom and this is the
second time any cargo related ability
has appeared on this list
poor poor octa body and it pretty much
amounts to a cargo turning his tent to
close into an air rifle so crafting a
gun which is
that's kind of uncreative and it's also
woefully inefficient because the rifle
needs to be recharged after every shot
and as for suitability and versatility
look it's average smack bang average
freedom just
doesn't do enough anywhere if anything
and doesn't deserve my praise go away
similarly to number six which is battle
waltz and this is always fun because
every time i make a hunt hunt video with
the word
worst in the title it is almost
guaranteed that guido or his ability are
going to show up in some form
and this is no different battle waltz is
a very cute use of nin more of a novelty
really with heavily restricted
versatility below average efficiency and
creativity
is pretty lackluster in fact the highest
score it receives in any era is 50
in versatility because even for a
warrior of heaven's arena let's be real
this kind of sucks and in keeping with
that theme of heaven's arena suckage we
are now back to castro with double in
fifth place so i kind of went over this
in the intro but the obvious factor that
plummets this hatsu is efficiency castro
is a natural enhancer who chose to dive
into both conjuration and manipulation
the two
most unfriendliest of affinities as such
the aura cost of double would be
exorbitant and the nature of the har2
would be incredibly limited as a result
but it certainly does garner some points
for creativity because it is actually
quite a clever use of nen
and one that we surprisingly don't see
all that often even from characters who
are much more friendly towards
conjuration and manipulation
speaking of friendly cheetu is not of
course his abilities were going to show
up and
tag ranks in fourth place which allows
its user to trap target in a pocket
dimension commencing a fun little game
of tag to be played out over the course
of 8 hours
and this is legitimately not a bad
ability in fact
it might even be good like many of the
ants this wasn't properly thought out
but there is a lot of potential the
reason why it lands in fourth place
however is purely suitability
tag is completely counter to cheetu's
goals desires and natural advantages and
if anything the very idea of tag hands
that advantage to his opponents
although the icing atop the cake of
shame is that cheeto doesn't even know
what would happen
if his ideal conditions of not being
caught for eight hours were met he
doesn't understand how his own abilities
work it could very potentially even
result in a negative effect for him so
very
very bad suitability for a bit of a
shock now in third place we have limited
transformation which is the ability that
really does solidify hunter hunter as
one of the most memorable anime among
series
in well in existence however that does
not make this
a good ability per se and you'll notice
that there is a mere one point in
efficiency and that's because limited
transformation basically acts as a
glorified suicide bomb
you exchange everything your nan your
potential and your life for a brief
brief period of
ultimate power which really only works
if you're gone actually because that
ultimate power would be significantly
less than anyone else trying to invoke
this style of effect
due to their lack of natural talent and
the only way you would ever want to use
this ability is to make sure that your
enemy dies alongside you which is a very
niche application of nen but it also
becomes less effective over time as you
do
actually reach your full potential so
you need to be super young willing to
die at a moment's notice and have
someone you want dead so badly
that you're willing to make all of the
above work so yeah not
not exactly the best of the powers great
drama though
great great drama still limited
transformation did receive more points
in our second place finisher which
is nen exorcism an advanced brand of
hatsu held by both abangana and the
chimera antenna and both of their
exorcisms are kind of being lumped
together because they are more or less
effectively the same thing non-exorcism
just has very little versatility
as far as we're aware it can only be
used to deal with nine curses and then
curses themselves are pretty exceedingly
rare and
in fact in this world as a whole nen use
in general is exceedingly rare so
there's very little opportunity to use
exorcism and even when you do stumble
upon said opportunity you need to be
ready to accept a detriment in direct
proportion to the curse you vanquished
it's unappealing on almost every level
basically saddling its user with an n
curse in that rare scenario where they
discover one to dispel
in the first place but at least it's not
our number one worst nun ability in
hunter hunter which according to my
statistics would be crossbow and claws
once again brought to us
by chitu yes the ability to conjure a
basic object with no special functions
worth crafting from aura and abysmally
low suitability to cheetah himself
considering that he is faster than the
crossbow
crossbow and claws is simply a desperate
show of stupidity and not an inability
that any one of us should ever aspire to
but if you'd like to see some abilities
that perhaps we should aspire to then
please do check out this video featuring
the top 10 best in abilities in the
series some really great stuff so i look
forward to seeing you there